[Music]
come back around on this side and we'll
send you in for the second time
thanks so much all right here we go
there goes nothing but even before i had
that swab stuck
basically into my brain i had a feeling
of what the result would be
i felt like i ate yeah
how did i know because i turned my body
into a kovid 19 detecting computer
with various wearable devices
yep all these send data about my body
via bluetooth to apps on my iphone
so why all those things so why all the
things
well because medical researchers and
tech companies have begun to see if
wearables can spot sickness
and right now they're very focused on
covid19
and even seeing if these wearables can
be an early detection system
each of these continuously monitors for
one or more possible covid19 indicators
higher body temperature heart rate
changes
low blood oxygen levels i'm going to
take you through each of these
but before that let me be clear about
something
none of these can tell you if you do or
don't have covid
that's why i recruited dr eric topple
executive vice president of scripps
research
well the problem is there's so much
confounding
potential of other things that could
cause
a mild elevation in temperature
a increase in resting heart rate
you know these parameters are
not that chris a signal for covid
only when they're together and only when
they're in a cluster of people do they
become the real deal
still i was committed to my experiment
i don't know if i'm gonna cough or throw
up in my mask number one temperature
tracking
my average temp for the last week
depends on what you ask
a fever is 100.4 according to the cdc
the 300 aura ring was the most
interesting to me
it's one of the only wearables that
takes temperature and it doesn't give
you a readout of your core temperature
like a regular thermometer
instead it figures out your baseline
temp over a few weeks and then reports
fluctuations
the thing that's great about the aura is
that it takes continuous temperature in
a comfortable way
a patch like this one from temp track
does continuous core temperature
but it's very uncomfortable and while i
like the kinza smart thermometer the
best
you have to remember to use it what does
all this temperature data tell you very
little
uh unfortunately the problem with
temperature is
uh more than half of people who have
copin 19 you know bona fide
infection they never mount a fever
response
and the other thing of course is that
you're particularly infectious
before you have a fever so what happens
before you have a temperature increase
is your heart rate goes up
many hours or even a day or two before
so the heart rate
resting is actually more sensitive than
a temperature which brings me to number
two heart rate and activity tracking
my average resting heart rate for the
last week according to aura
54 beats per minute garmin apple and
fitbit said
60 beats per minute aura says it only
measures heart rate at night
hence the lower average 30 to 40 percent
of infections of cova
are asymptomatic no symptoms but you
should be able to pick them up if your
heart rate your body is reacting to it
even though you don't have symptoms so
the fact that your heart rate has never
gone up is a really good sign that
there's nothing
going on whether it's covert or anything
else
i mean you're not even under stress even
okay well let's be clear i am under
stress
okay okay researchers have started to
look at heart rate
respiratory activity and sleep data and
people who test positive for covid19
once the studies and more of the
research is done the idea is that these
wearables could get algorithms that
would look at our data and give us some
early warning
fitbit ceo james park told me that's the
company's goal with its own study
a user could receive a alert that's
color-coded green yellow red
and then they can assess whether they
need to self-quarantine based on that
risk assessment
and then follow up with a physician for
a traditional nasal swap test
aura is already doing something similar
with the nba in the orlando bubble
wearers are notified if data points hit
certain levels
[Music]
number three blood oxygen tracking my
average blood oxygen level this week
from a walgreens pulse oximeter 98
the garmin 96 a low blood oxygen level
something in the 80 or low 90 percent
range can be a signal for covid19
which has made pulse oximeters the
hottest gadget of the year
but if you have one of garmin's latest
wearables you don't need to buy one
it's built right in dr topple said my
scores looked good
but that with blood oxygen it's only
helpful for people already diagnosed
with covid19 to gauge the severity of
the illness
there's one last thing our wearables
might end up with
cough monitoring this patch from
northwestern being used in studies
tracked my coughs and even my throat
clears
according to the readouts i was all good
and then it was finally time to ask
do i have coven no you don't have covert
i'll rest my case you don't have covert
uh
of course you have to have a test to
prove that a few days later my official
test results said the same thing
and maybe the best thing about this
wearable data is telling you if you
should get a test or not
so the way i look at it is in the months
ahead
people will have at their home a testing
kit that will give them the answer in 15
minutes
and they'll also be using wearables if
they're smart
because they already have these devices
largely
and so you wouldn't do the test unless
either you had symptoms or your sensors
were
were coming together that there's
something going on the one problem with
that is that some of the communities hit
hardest by covid19
may not have access to these sometimes
pricey wearables
but at least you don't need to own or
wear
all the things at once